you'd think that August would be a slow
month for video games as we march
inexorably towards the busy fall season
but in 2015 this was not the case there
was more than enough to tide us over
until the highly anticipated launch of
Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain on
the first day of September whether it
was action you were looking for
something a little more mellow and
retrospective or an adventure
packed with jump scares and gore the end
of summer had something for nearly
everyone August you could say with the
month of choice for some of the more
sought-after
indie games the month kicked off with
galaxy an anime inspired shooter from
developer 17 bits that captured our
hearts and inspired us to best our own
runs over and over again Thomas was
alone creator Mike Bethel launched his
next game volume volume hit the sweet
spot for those of us craving something
stealth based a story reminiscent of
Robin Hood guided us through Bethel's
Metal Gear inspired world which seems to
take the best of Kojima's tactical
espionage adventures and distilled them
into bite-sized puzzles and mid-month
developer the Chinese room launched its
PlayStation 4 exclusive everybody's gone
to the rapture a heartbreaking tale
about love loss and the end of the world
this month also saw the return of an old
classic with new polish Gears of War
Ultimate Edition brought us back to
where it all started helping us relive
our nostalgia with a fresh coat of paint
while the remastered edition wasn't
quite the same masterpiece as the
original we still found much to love
supermassive games is until dawn
another ps4 exclusive topped off the
month delivering us a brilliant survival
horror game wrapped in slasher flick
tropes when thinking back on August its
until dawn that we remember most fondly
we here a game spot were captivated by
it dedicating ourselves to an overnight
stream of the game and a horrid
quickly entertaining death compilation
the game almost has no right being as
good as it is it surprised us delighted
us and in the end we decided that
there's no way we can't not applaud this
engaging little gem